governments are ramping up their moves
to contain the corona virus as it
spreads globally Japan is among those
governments Prime Minister Shinzo Abe
has called for all public schools to
close from next Monday until the end of
spring break in April this as new
infections of the virus outside China
outnumber those in China let's take a
look at a map that shows the severity of
the situation in the affected nations
now the deeper blue the country here the
larger the number of reported cases and
as you can see China still has the
highest number of cases more than 78,000
altogether 50 countries or territories
have confirmed cases of the virus
the total stands at more than 82,000 now
South Korea has again seen its biggest
one-day jump in of infections and Saudi
Arabia has stopped traveled to religious
pilgrimage sites due to fears over the
virus in Europe Italy's outbreak has
worsened
while Romania Denmark and Estonia are
the latest countries to confirm cases
and Australia's taking emergency
measures to stop the disease from
spreading numerous international flights
have been cut back or canceled here's a
closer look at how countries around the
world are fighting to ward off a
pandemic streets deserted as infections
search in Italy several new cases across
Europe more deaths reported in South
Korea and many global events from
sporting matches to conferences canceled
around the world preparations are
ramping up as fears of the virus turning
into a pandemic grow Australia has
kicked off emergency measures
the w-h-o is yet to declare the nature
of the corona virus and it's moved
towards a pandemic phase we believe that
the risk of a global pandemic is very
much upon us and as a result as a
government we need to take the steps
necessary to prepare for such a pandemic
as the number of cases in the Middle
East rise travel to holy sites in Saudi
Arabia has been halted months in advance
of the annual Hajj pilgrimage even North
Korea yet to report a single case is
taking preventative measures closing its
borders and postponing the new school
term the viruses epicenter in Wuhan in
China remains the worst hit most of the
reported deaths and cases are in the
city and the surrounding Hubei province
but as China's infection rates slow the
virus is now spreading faster elsewhere
more and more countries are reporting
cases and upping their efforts to
contain outbreaks we can speak now to
Christiane linnemeier he's a spokesman
for the World Health Organization and he
joins us from Geneva Christian good to
have you here on DW this outbreak has
now is now global it is affected nearly
every continent 82,000 cases where does
your organization the w-h-o put its
focus and tackling this outbreak and
focuses the one is of course in China
the source of the outbreak as we know
here as the report also said we have
actually good news that means we have
declining cases and we have less for
second time in a row now less cases
inside China than outside China the
flipside of that coin is exactly the
other side that we have now more cases
outside of China then we have inside
China which is our second priority to
look at and we have been calling the
World Health Organization has been
calling upon the countries of the world
since weeks to vamp up their response
and to prepare for exactly that scenario
and preparing means a lot preparing
means getting your health system ready
getting your health care workers ready
and protect them because these are the
first who would normally have to field
any a sick patient or any patient with
symptoms so we need countries of the
world need to protect their health care
workers that's step one the second is
preparing or protecting the vulnerable
population that's the patients with
underlying conditions or the other
the week and third of course it needs a
lot of information and helping those
countries who are not as strong in
responding to this outbreak Kristen I
want to ask you about that flipside
because this is extremely worrying I
mean why are we seeing this spread and
infections to places where there doesn't
appear to be a direct link to the
epicenter in China it's a good point in
which we still have to understand more
so most and the vast majority of all
infections come from symptomatic people
and from those who we can trace back at
the link but it seems or we still have
to understand more about how possibly
asymptomatic people have been
transporting the virus and then have
been showing up in countries or
infecting others without the direct link
yet back to the origin so these tests
and these looking into history of
travelers of infection history is
ongoing because we need to understand
that how these infections are possible
how they come about if there is a link
or if there's no link and if there's no
link where these infections come from
okay we are seeing people-to-people
transmission of course we're seeing
deaths from these cases should this be
declared a pandemic I mean what would
that provide your organization so the
World Health Organization has already
ranked the highest alert that is
possible in our system that is the
acceleration of a public health
emergency of international concern this
is a mechanism which was declared
already a month ago pandemic would mean
that the outbreak has reached levels
where it's in multiple countries outside
of the origin not containable or
widespread community transmission so we
believe we haven't seen this said we
have seen many countries being hit by
the virus that is for sure
but most of these countries still have a
good grip on these individual outbreaks
they contain the people they contain
they treat the patients they trace the
contacts and trace all the people who
have possibly been infected on the way
they quarantine people or instruct them
to self-monitor for a while so as long
as this is under control this is good
news but there is a very high potential
as the colleague also just mentioned of
this reaching pandemic
levers and once it reached it was
certainly talking in those terms it's
but let's not make this mistake here the
effort of response is not limited or
related to whether we call it a pandemic
or not or whether the world concert a
pandemic or not the efforts a country
can do the efforts the individual can do
the efforts every health system can do
are there yet and will be alright we'll
have to leave it there Christian in my a
spokesman for the World Health
Organization thank you for joining us
thank you now here in Germany the
government has set up an emergency task
force to deal with what the health
minister says is the beginning of an
epidemic the country has seen 10 new
cases since Tuesday a couple is being
treated at a hospital in Dusseldorf and
schools and kindergartens in their town
have been closed while officials try to
trace a train of infection
health minister Yanis bond has urged
regional authorities to review their
emergency planning give evidence and
begin we're at the beginning of a corona
virus epidemic in Germany the cases in
North rhine-westphalia and
baden-württemberg are a further sign of
this the chains of infection are partly
and this is a new aspect not traceable
there are multiple persons who have had
contact with the infected patients and
that's a qualitative difference to the
16 infectious cases we've already had in
Germany where in each case the chain of
infection could be traced back to the
outbreak in China